Ladies and gentlemen, it's Tom Selleck.
(audience cheers)
Hiya Drew, nice to meet you, by the way.
I don't think we've ever met.
I know,
and I've loved you for so long.
I love your work too.
I really have.
And I was just so excited to talk to you.
And of course, we love here on the show to take look backs
at people's career, because look,
I've been kicking it since I was in diapers.
And it's Beauty Week here on the show
and you kind of started in hygiene and beauty commercials.
I was very big on hygiene commercials,
no hemorrhoid commercials, though.
I draw the line.
It's not over yet, Tom.
(audience laughs)
Well, I got nothing against hemorrhoids
or hemorrhoid commercials
but that's not me.
I have managed to stave off
a hemorrhoid commercial myself.
But again, you know, it's not over yet.
I mean, what incredible longevity
and board vision you have had.
Another thing that we have in common is Charlie's Angels.
You did an episode back in the day.
Yeah, I did!
What was that like?
It was, they were trying to experiment with boyfriends
for the Angels
and I was gonna be Jacque Smith's boyfriend.
And my boss on Blue Bloods,
I'm sitting here at the Blue Bloods dining room table.
Anyway, my boss Leonard Goldberg had a lot to do
with Charlie's Angels.
And I always remind him that my part didn't end
up reoccurring.
They fired me after the first episode.
Well,
My boss on Blue Bloods actually fired me
from Charlie's Angels.
I like to kid Leonard about that.
By the way, I saw a picture of you,
I don't know if it was from Charlie's Angels,
but it was mustacheless.
Yes, that's possible.
I was born without it.
(Drew and audience laughs)
It's hard to believe because
I don't feel like I know you without it.
I don't know what's going on under there now,
it's been so long.
I mean, 11 years of Blue Bloods
I haven't shaved this thing off.
So..
Well, let's talk Blue Bloods, 11 seasons
of this beloved show on CBS.
I mean, fans love the Sunday dinner scenes.
And when I was reading about how close you guys are,
is it true that you almost have a hard time
getting work done because
you're being little rascals with each other?
Yeah, well, you know,
as you know, you can work on an ensemble picture
on a lot of television shows.
I could go weeks and weeks and not see a lot
of my cast members 'cause they're doing different scenes
and everything else.
On our show, once the show we have a family dinner and
look, I love these people.
They're all close friends.
So, we have a family reunion every once a week
on the show, but we also have a personal reunion
(laughs)
and one, sometimes gets in the way of the other.
It's great.
One thing I wanted to ask you about, Tom
as someone who has had such longevity
and a lifelong career, almost
I talked to Eddie Murphy about this
and I had such a great conversation
because I've been in this business
and working my whole entire life since I was in diapers.
When do you know to say, you know what?
I have to lean out.
I have to put family first.
You know what, I know when to drive
for career first
and everything will find its balance.
Second, where did you find the work-life balance?
I think it's something you have to learn.
You know, the thing that did it for me
I had done a movie in Japan that I'm proud of,
Mr. Baseball about an American player,
we were over there and
that was 4 months.
And yeah, Jillie and Hannah came over.
Hannah was a little girl,
but just for a visit.
So, I got home and I got offered this movie
where I got to work with Marlon Brando.
Well, he's, you know, kind of the man
(laughs)
in my generation.
It actually, wasn't a really very good script
and it turned out to be a lousy movie.
(laughs)
It was Christopher Columbus at discovery.
I was so thrilled with the idea
of working with Marlon Brando that I just said
I gotta go, but here's what happened.
My daughter got viral pneumonia before I left.
So, I stayed as many days as I could
before going to Madrid where we're gonna shoot it.
She was out of the hospital the day I left, but
it really bothered me.
And it really was, I don't know whether it was an ego trip
but it was, it, it was the work out of balance with life.
Yeah, I went and did the movie,
the movie wasn't really worth doing, frankly
I think Marlon was really in it for getting $5 million
for two weeks work and
it just bothered me.
So, I took a year off
and a year off, turned into three, frankly.
I love the work, but it gets out of balance.
Well, I love talking to you about that
because we're all trying to figure it out
in life as human beings, regardless of your occupation.
And I applaud you for having that self-awareness
and finding a work-life balance that works for you.
And it's just something I think about all the time
now that I'm a mom.
So, thank you for that conversation.
(vibrant music)